So here's my question again and this is the model that we agreed upon. let's pair
some math with this model.I would have one stamp plus 2 piles of 3 or 2 times of
3. Okay, here's what exiting about this math. I can actually calculate this math
two ways, I could do 1 plus 2 and get 3 times 3 which is 9 or I can do 2 times 3
which is 6 and then add 1 which is 7. I know that the second answer must be
correct. I have 7 stamps in my diagram so I know that I need to do
multiplication first. This 2 has a choice. It can either go with multiplication
or it could go with addition. I know multiplication takes priority. That's so
that way I can get the correct answer of 7. Just like in my model. Okay, so when
I think about the order of operations, I know multiplication occurs before
addition. Multiplication has to happen before addition. It's at a higher
priority level. It turns out that multiplication is also done before
subtraction. We know this because subtraction is the same as adding the
opposite. For example, 3 minus 1 times 2. Subtracting a positive 1 is the same
thing as adding a negative 1 or adding the opposite. So I can have 3 plus
negative 1 times 2. Here the negative 1 can go with either the multiplication or
the addition. I know that multiplication comes first, it has higher priority. So
I should do 3 plus negative 2 and I get 1. So when thinking about the order of
operations, we know addition and subtraction should be on the bottom, they come
last. Multiplication should come before addition and subtraction I'm going to
keep track of our order of operations right here, and we'll come back to this
later. Alright, let's check your understanding of this with a quiz.